when you don't know how hard it's gonna
be or the challenges ahead you kind of
just take them one day at a time if they
come versus being too scared to get
started
I'm Annie Wallace and I'm the co-founder
of Suja juice and the creator of the
blog's long calm and I'm 28 years old
growing up I had celiac disease and that
is an autoimmune intolerance to gluten
so I had eczema all over my body and I
really found out that it was caused from
my gluten intolerance well I started
juicing and my energy just got so much
better and I started feeling so much
healthier and more vibrant and I decided
to stick with it ever since learn
everything I could about it I was just
making juices with my best friend Eric
out of our houses and we were just doing
a local home delivery service throughout
San Diego as traction grew and more and
more people got interested
we were really presented with some
opportunities to grow in the form of our
two partners and initial investors and
one of them is now our CEO they really
had a business mind and could understand
how to take this small local home
delivery service and make it something
so much bigger I'm really inspired by
making people's lives better whether
it's through juice whether it's through
sharing something on my blog that I'm
struggling with that really speaks to
somebody who might be having the same
problem they really are the reason that
I get to do what I'm doing and they
really should show the direct benefit of
my work